todos hablamos de la privacidad y del
acceso que tienen las redes sociales a
nuestra información pero muy pocas veces
hablamos del potencial que tienen las
redes para ayudarnos a mejorar nuestras
estrategias en el emprendimiento
en lugar de asustarnos por el control de
la privacidad debemos entender cómo
usarla a nuestro favor no me
malinterpreten todos tenemos derecho a
nuestra privacidad pero a las redes no
le importan nuestras conversaciones las
redes sociales nos proporcionan una
lista de posibles clientes muy grandes
basada en interacciones a qué páginas le
das like qué tipo de páginas visitas
cuáles son los vídeos que consumes en
fin todo el tiempo que tú pasas en la
red toda esta información se guarda en
una base de datos en las redes sociales
para crear los arquetipos que no son más
que un conjunto de perfiles unidos por
características e intereses
imaginemos que buscamos clientes para un
gimnasio si lo hacemos del modo
tradicional primero es muy tedioso y nos
va a tomar mucho tiempo vamos a arrancar
entregando volantes para que la gente
nos conozca en la zona hacer un par de
encuestas esperar que la gente tenga
pues tiempo de contestar nuestras
preguntas que conteste con la verdad de
hablar el contenido encontrar los
posibles arquetipos hacer un par de
llamadas para ofrecer nuestros servicios
y esperar que la gente venga al gimnasio
ahora hagamos el mismo ejercicio
utilizando los filtros de las redes
sociales
primero segmentamos el lugar en donde
tenemos el gimnasio
elegimos intereses y características que
buscamos en nuestros arquetipos recuerda
en la encuesta que hicimos pues muchas
personas mienten que no lo ha hecho pero
es muy difícil mentirle a las redes
sociales ya que se basa en algoritmos de
todos los gustos que tenemos para
concluir elegimos la segmentación de
edad el rango de edad que buscamos y
lanzamos nuestra campaña facebook se va
a encargar de llegar a miles de personas
que cumplen con las características que
deseamos así hemos gastado menos dinero
hemos optimizado tiempo y sobre todo
hemos llegado a muchas más personas al
convertirnos en emprendedores digitales
es muy importante aprender a crear
nuestros arquetipos ya que si no sabemos
a quién le queremos vender
es muy difícil trazar una estrategia que
funciona vamos a ponerlo con un ejemplo
para que quede más claro volvamos a
nuestro gimnasio imaginemos que queremos
vender inscripciones hay varios
arquetipos a quienes les podemos vender
el mismo producto y el mismo servicio
por ejemplo las descripciones del
gimnasio tenemos la persona fit la que
quiere cuidar su línea
la persona que le encanta ir al gimnasio
porque le encanta hacer vida social
tenemos la persona que quiere
simplemente ir al gimnasio por bajar de
peso o la que va al gimnasio por cuidar
algún problema de salud que tienen las
campañas publicitarias se hacen
estratégicamente para cada uno de los
arquetipos y estas campañas tienen
gatillos mentales que lo que hacen es
activar comportamientos y acciones en
las personas en el primer ejemplo del
arquetipo fit pues vamos a destacar cómo
mantener su apariencia física te
imaginas tener solo una prenda para usar
y que se vea así de bien y utilizamos un
gatillo mental de urgencia durante la
siguiente hora te puedes escribir con el
50% de descuento en el caso que queramos
llegar al arquetipo de la persona que
quiere bajar de peso podemos destacar el
método aire que es lo que hacen atención
interés deseo y acción como destacamos
la atención entrenamiento para perder
peso un interés quieres bajar de peso y
no sabes por dónde empezar destacamos un
deseo te gustaría volver a tu peso ideal
y todo esto para un llamado a la acción
es darle click aquí para valorarte
gratis
ahora el arquetipo de la persona que
quiere cuidar su salud podemos conectar
mediante una pregunta te interesa tu
salud luego un beneficio conjuntamente
con un incentivo una vez que asistas a
una clase gratuita notarás la diferencia
en cómo te sientes y ahora buscamos
conectar mediante un miedo no vuelvas a
poner en riesgo tu salud con
entrenamientos que no funcionan
dependiendo con cuál de las campañas
interactúan nuestros arquetipos ingresan
en un embudo de ventas el embudo lo que
hace es transformar a las personas que
no conocen nuestra empresa en personas
que quieren comprar nuestro producto la
campaña de nuestro gimnasio está
conformada por vídeos que van dirigidos
a cada uno de los arquetipos después les
llegará un mail con toda la información
y dependiendo la acción que tengan en
este caso si es positiva en el embudo se
sigue construyendo y termina en la
compra de una inscripción en caso
contrario si la acción es negativa vamos
a enviar después de unos cinco días más
o menos otro mail que tiene en la
siguiente campaña porque no te has
inscrito crees que la oferta no es tan
buena tenemos otros planes para ti
recuerden que la intención es que la
gente vuelve al embudo para que concrete
las ventas al personalizar las campañas
hemos logrado que personas que tienen
objetivos completamente diferentes
compren el mismo producto y el mismo
servicio estas estrategias no solamente
funcionan para un gimnasio realmente las
puedes utilizar en cualquier
emprendimiento
nosotros somos los únicos que conocemos
muy bien a nuestros clientes es por eso
que tenemos que elegir las
características y los intereses para
crear un arquetipo que posteriormente lo
podemos utilizar en una campaña de
publicidad nadie mejor que nosotros para
manejar nuestros emprendimientos por eso
es muy importante
convertirnos en emprendedores
autosuficientes y grandes de empresas
como amazon como wal mart pueden tener
éxito con este tipo de estrategias
porque un emprendimiento pequeño no
[Aplausos]